yes we've airports are a high fixed cost
business you
even if we only have one passenger we
still need to keep the whole airfield
safe and
secure and all the equipment moving and
we've worked
so hard over the last 12 months to get
our costs down by about a third
but of course there's only so much that
we can do particularly when the
government isn't giving us any relief on
business rates which is a
a big chunk of our cost base but we are
now starting to see signs that
passengers are coming back
people want to be able to travel and as
soon as we can start to get borders open
up again
and start to see doubly vaccinated
passengers from the eu
and the u.s traveling again we will
start to see our
uh our business recovering and with it
the uk economy
to what extent are you being hurt by
workers having to self-isolate right now
i mean it's been widely reported over
the weekend that there was a lot of
chaos on the ground at heathrow
we've had a couple of incidents where a
lot of people have been pinged
all at the same time which is very hard
to manage even with the daily contact
testing
system which we do have in place here
but it's a good system and it means that
we can keep the airport flowing and keep
getting passengers and
the uk's exports on their way but the
the main thing we need to do
is to start looking to the future get
doubly vaccinated passengers traveling
and also make it easier with
pcr tests uh getting rid of pcr tests
for people coming from low risk
countries
and replacing them with lateral flow
tests just to cut the cost
and the hassle that comes with travel
today
sorry just to go back to what happened
what was wrong at the weekend what what
specifically went wrong
so we had an issue in border force for a
couple of hours
when we had a combination of a lot of
officers being pinged and not being able
to uh man the desks
and at the same time the e-gates which a
lot of passengers traveled through
also went down and that led to cues of a
couple of hours for a short period
but i'm in terminal five at the moment
and speaking to passengers
they are amazed at how quickly they are
getting through immigration in just a
couple of minutes
so it shows this is uh what happened at
the weekend was the unusual
circumstance usually people get through
very quickly
you've reopened terminal 3 11 days ago
how has that gone thus far
it's gone really well and it's good to
have a bit more capacity
for passengers in particular one of the
consequences of all the checks that have
to be put in place is that it takes a
little bit longer to check in now
than it would normally take it can take
10 or 15 minutes for
the check-in agents to make sure that
you've got all the paperwork you'll need
to get into the country you're going to
and that means we just need a little bit
more space
in check-in and that's why we've opened
terminal 3 earlier
but we're also anticipating that the
demand will come back in the second half
of this year
and we want to get the whole airport up
and running again so we can meet that
demand and help to get britain traveling
again
and get the economy off the ground and
it's shocking today
seeing how low our cargo volumes have
fallen
and you know that we are the biggest uk
port we carry 40
of uk exports and yet our volumes of
cargo are down by 20
when countries like germany and the
netherlands are up by nearly 10 percent
and that shows that their more
progressive approach to opening borders
is helping their economy at the expense
of ours
and it's a bit like we've won the race
for vaccination and yet we don't even
get into the medals because we're not
prepared to
follow up and get the benefits of the
vaccination program
i mean obviously a lot of cargo uh
normally travels
in the in the hold along with uh
passenger flights to what extent are you
seeing more airlines running cargo only
flights
we've seen a big uplift in past in cargo
only flights but the great thing about
cargo that goes in the belly of
passenger planes is that those planes
are traveling
every single day of the week sometimes
many times a day
and that means that if you're a uk
exporter trying to get your goods to
market
it's cheap and quick to get them to any
part of the world
if you're depending on a cargo only
flight that plane might only be going
once a week
which adds to the supply chain time and
adds to the cost of getting it to market
one of the great advantages that uk
businesses have is the connectivity from
heathrow which normally
is the best of any airport in the world
means they can get their goods and their
people
anywhere they want to in the world
within 24 hours
and we have lost that advantage because
of these restrictions on passengers
flying we can get it back we just need
to be more optimistic
and and to open up to doubly vaccinated
passengers from more countries
and reduce the friction of travel by
getting rid of these
expensive pcr tests from low-risk
countries
now that free shopping is now a thing of
the past how concerned are you that more
retailers are going to follow the lead
of dixons who are now of course
closing all their airport stores well
yes it's a real shame to see dickson's
uh move out i'm very pleased that w h
smith is stepping in to take their place
and we do have a lot of demand from
retailers to have stores
in the airport it's an important part of
the passenger journey people look
forward to starting their holiday or
their trip
once they get to the airport and either
to sock up on things that they haven't
been able to
uh to buy before or to treat themselves
so we currently have about 75 percent of
all of our stores and restaurants open
and we'll be looking to get that up to a
hundred percent as soon as we can
all right john holland good to talk to
you as ever thanks for joining me this
morning